a unidade de médicos e pesquisadores em
geral o conhecimento do ato de uma
sociedade causou vítimas muitas delas
infelizmente muitas pessoas e famílias
ainda oscilam em torno de aceitar
dinheiro
esse novo capítulo de uma história que
ainda não foi completamente esquina
apenas os primeiros capítulos foram
escritos e hoje eu gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês um pouco das
histórias música começou na verdade
chamar da área e uganda
exatamente a floresta se que em 1964 não
pensou dentro de uma floresta foi
infectada pelo vírus china forma leve da
doença
depois disso os casos aconteceu de forma
esporádica de forma isolada até que a
doença mudou de padrão do inseto nas
ilhas de atos e 2013 principalmente na
polinésia francesa o rio grande às 13 10
% da população era cometida com música
na sua forma leve da doença em público
eles
daí o vírus foi até o brasil
especificamente no nordeste só tomou
grandes dimensões em um ano ela se diz
que sou 49 países da américa
ela tá local fica milhões de pessoas
foram acometidas
mas o que mudou na verdade o vírus
sofrer uma mutação com músicas
brasileira demonstrou isso mostrando que
a mudança nos surgem na sua genética que
aumentar essa capacidade de replicação e
transmissão inclusive causando doenças
graves com os 4 lógico a tudo e das
crianças
essa história da epidemia no brasil tem
vários capítulos
o primeiro capítulo acontece e de
janeiro março de 2015 quando várias
pessoas milhares delas foram atendidas
na unidade de saúde do nordeste porque
já basta
é e calçado que os olhos um pouco
vermelho um pouco de dólar de 46 técnico
com a fé
essa inclusive foi chamado pela ilha uma
doença misteriosa
naquela ocasião a no grupo de
pesquisadores que lhe estudando a pilha
de chininha e até essa questão clara
daquele grupo é que não se tratava de
esquina característica 30 é bastante
diferente e apesar das autoridades
desistiram na possibilidade que havia
uma de leve o grupo que uma certeza essa
não era a característica cria da adm que
nós afirmamos é que esse grupo é pensada
de forma unânime é tratado assim
provavelmente um vírus transmitido pelo
mosquito e precisa se dedicar à causa
até que o pesquisador a dura do nó do
problema pelos levantou a possibilidade
poderia secar vírus
até que em maio foi comprovada no sangue
dos pacientes que aquela que ele lia era
decorrente dos cabelos
o segundo capítulo nessa história
acontece a partir do mês de maio a chuva
em 2015 enquanto no nordeste percebeu um
aumento no número de casos neurológicos
um adulto
a chamada síndrome de guillain barre o
fato já havia sido visto na polinésia
francesa mas o vírus ainda não tinha
sido isolada até que pernambuco doutora
lúcia brito do grupo da fiocruz de
pernambuco visão adultos com esse quadro
neurológico funcionando na meta do
sangue e identificou pela primeira vez
no mundo
a presença desse vírus em quadro
neurológico do ano passado e segundo
capítulo v terceiro capítulo dessa
história que se inicia no segundo
semestre 15 dois neurologistas de
nomeados procurando evidenciar
bandeirinha mas só percebeu um aumento
do número de casos de crianças que
nasceram comigo
falei pra vocês terem idéia a média dos
anos anteriores ainda escassos de
crianças mas sim como você faria
ou seja uma média de um caso público só
que o pico da epidemia do caso de
crianças com hidrocefalia outubro num
hospital
muita semana havia um 24 crianças como
josé cunha foi que essas neurologistas
que inclui também notória dela henrique
gado pra mim a pensar qual seria a
hipótese relacionadas a esses casos de
microcefalia da nossa corte inicial era
que esses carros principalmente de surto
já conhecidos por que você faria ela
leva casos e até morrem de infecções de
mercado ouvidos aos famosos com ela
todas as empresas podem se levar caso
domingos e faria no dia seguinte do
douro reduzido menezes responsável por
isso a unidade de pediatria referência
do estado pernambuco imip reunir essas
mães de duas aulas nessa foto histórica
onde se realizou a primeira investigação
da educação física com amigos e família
são várias ruas de duas salas com suas
crianças com amigos ea família
eu levei um questionário questionada por
alguns experimentos na tentativa de
encontrar pistas que pudesse justificar
decote além do sido levantadas se até
com relação entre essas ruas
o fato é que já no primeiro momento
quando a gente diz que aplicou
questionários surgiram como surpresas
pelo fato que chamou a atenção do
empresário depois eram oriundas de
diferentes cidades do estado perto do
público estava com 92 mil quilômetros
quadrados estava descartada várias das
empresas de porte porque não seria
possível o vírus como dela é transmitida
de pessoa a pessoa através de público
disperso uma força total nesta primeira
taça dos pacientes não se conhecia
demorar muito distante não estava só
então o que outros vírus como nem
poderia atacar os organizadores
até que em um dado chamou a atenção de
70% dessas mães
três vigias disseram que tiveram quadro
viral número de geremi março isso na
gestação da vida burguesa
esperávamos que pudéssemos contar sua
história fosse a história em caso de
dissídio citomegalovírus mas eu tenho
uma grande surpresa trouxe um prejuízo
grande susto porque é o que ela tem de
escrever era exatamente a característica
clínica básica
aquilo que nós que o investimento
inicial no início do ano
aqui na verdade uma surpresa e um grande
susto
e essa característica desse
comportamento dessa doença nessa questão
falar fortemente que a transmissão pelo
provedor
provavelmente o chip a presente em todo
o estado de pernambuco e um fato que
chama a atenção é que nós já sabíamos lá
em maio junho desse vírus ele tem uma
predileção pelo cérebro
ele foi capaz de levar a não celebrar os
alunos do ist cada hipótese que esse
dinheiro poderia estar levando essas
alterações do sistema nervoso central
nessas crianças mas faltava um elemento
nessa tese para fechar esse quebra
cabeça
precisamos saber se outro estado de
missouri física também há casos de
microcefalia league pelo pré pagos no
rio grande do norte e pediu que fizesse
uma investigação 24 horas depois da
medida também assustado desejo que o
único modelo permeava estava dentro de
oito casos de microcefalia muito mais do
que ele tenha estrutura sua história a
minha vez fechado até a cabeça na
hipótese da associação de física como
livros e família é apenas uma hipótese
mas a hipótese mais forte naquele
momento até comunicamos o fato pela
primeira vez a um ministério da saúde
junto com a secretaria de saúde do
estado fez o alerta informou aos
técnicos que a hipótese que poderia ser
um foco em obras a ser investigada mas
colocar uma lente
a gente precisava identificar a presença
desse vírus naquelas crianças como você
avalia até que vieram outros
pesquisadores uma delas cultura adriana
melo da paraíba viu gestante estava
naquele momento
mas eu não estava comigo você faria e
ela fez uma função de um pouco de
líquido capacita e recobrir aquela
criança e nesse livro ela mandou tinha
um do rio de janeiro
ninguém ficou pela primeira vez a
presença dos cabelos em casa depois a
família se fecharem um cílio as outras
evidências científicas se somar peças
importantes na defesa civil voltam os
pesquisadores condutor salina turk e
combinou um grupo de pesquisadores do
estado pernambuco tem um papel
fundamental reforçar em confirmar a
hipótese da associação de física como é
que você faria se tornou uma referência
internacional na produção de
conhecimento e assim com ela de outro
estado do trabalho do estado do rio de
janeiro e muitos dos castanhos
nunca se viu em tão curto espaço de
tempo e quantidade mobilização de tantos
pesquisadores nacionais e internacionais
todos que busca encontrar uma solução
entender essa relação da música cômica
sua família
os valores porém mim muitos andaram a
tragédia que uniu continente e essas
descobertas
essas condições críticas elas foram
extremamente pobre
gostaria a partir desse momento com
vocês
outro ponto de vista gostaria de
convidar vocês olhem em volta
nesse aspecto importante que a gente
entenda que há ainda muitos problemas a
serem resolvidos
primeiro a gente precisa entender que o
problema está longe de acabar
o que acontece caso de aprender que a
visita da falta investimento em melhoria
de condições de vida da população
o crescimento populacional da
urbanização não planejada sem saneamento
básico sem armamento nada como tenho a
brincar nada com ninguém aguenta nada de
desabastecimento a polícia esse é o
cenário aliás essa chamada tecnicamente
de imprensa nega iniciada fruto da
negligência da falta de cuidado
a falta de investimento
foi na metade a melhoria de condições de
vida da população em parte culpa do
cidadão de 90 eliminar o mosquito no seu
domicílio de todos nós temos uma
responsabilidade muito grande de forma
individual ou coletiva em ajudar etapas
formais na qual tanto que a gente também
faça parte desse processo não age como
apenas paciência mas de forma que é
preciso dar uma olha em volta como edson
as vítimas dessa tragédia eu queria
partilhar com vocês algumas dessas peles
uma delas do tamanho dele quando a
imagem de logística são preocupados e dá
a melhor tratamento da pescada
neurológico do adulto os pesquisadores
estão debruçados tentando identificá
aula nessa época teria acontecido uma
história de amor corria paralelo abdou
um médico renomado anestesiologista
professor congresso portanto e diretor
lá em pernambuco mostrou que referência
e subitamente começou a apresentar um
quadro clínico numerosos uma kombi loss
física e rapidamente ele uma orientação
não é conhecida mas a família tem com
parada respiratória e foi com uma amiga
sua filha dela de forma inesperada uma
doença negligenciada software e depois
de dois meses graças a deus resposta dos
médicos
ele se recuperou com uma história com
final feliz mas infelizmente nem muitas
dessas famílias não tiveram a mesma
sorte nessa história olhando em torno do
dom antonio ele pediu ainda em
recuperação em casa fizesse uma coisa
que a história ele fosse contada de uma
forma inclusive que fosse publicada pelo
serviço
nós fizemos isso porque queria que
outros profissionais de saúde
isso é captar dessa doença eu percebi
naquele momento eu já estava de volta
ele sabia que com a atitude individual
de licuri relógio gatos com mais se na
assim como a história de antônio ea
história de ana júlia e muitas outras
mães quando lado eles o ano no máximo
mas estávamos investigando essa doença
misteriosa ela engravidou teve o seu
filho em outubro ele fez parte daquela
investigação inicial quando os médicos
não é o momento de conhecimento de sua
criança tenha microcefalia agora chamada
síndrome congênita e assim como na
escolha muitas outras mães passaram pela
mesma situação
ganso se imaginava ver que toda uma
gestação em planejar desejada
o projeto desenvolvido projetos dos seus
filhos uma profissão não inclusive
revelou que desejava que seu filho fosse
engenheiro que achava a profissão dele
há dois meses atrás não podiam ajudar lá
na fundação altino ventura elas muitas
outras mães também natura para aferir
que as circunstâncias da vida tomar
assim ela inclusive apesar de 17 anos
falava em nome do grupo
ela falava que na verdade hoje passados
dois anos a ter muitos problemas e
dificuldades em conseguir medicamentos
em alguns momentos mais conhecido
dificuldade de transporte dessas mães
das duas crianças fazendo suas consultas
são necessárias em uma semana
a dificuldade completa porque é uma
dessas crianças utilizam sondagem da
casca e precisa ser limitado de arte
especiais 300 400 mães lista de espera
diferente com da suspeitando buscar a
reabilitação
sem dúvida aos envolvidos muito nessa
história da visita mas a gente ainda tem
muito a evoluir nesse cenário a história
quanto a nós que me fez um pedido ela
queria ter alguma forma eu pudesse falar
sobre estes problemas dessas vítimas é
também não se falou eu não entendia que
naquele momento a atitude individual
dela em são paulo e finalmente ela sabia
que poderia transformar de alguma forma
foi aí que aconteceu deve xixi de
convidar para fazer seu palácio e vou
contar essa história da descoberta
significa que eu disse ok vamos falar a
descoberta da pérola encontro é preciso
que a gente olhe exatamente o que está
acontecendo em toda essa tragédia
é claro que ao longo desse período a
gente tem vários exemplos que são
realmente animadores act fundação altino
ventura a união de mais que ama a liga e
pediatria à universidade de pernambuco
upe defeito ações junto a essas mães e
suas crianças como você faria
sem dúvida sua atitude de amor e
criatividade de doação principalmente do
álcool é diva elas estão ajudando a
transformar em cenário todos tom ele
olhando em volta
muito freqüentemente a questão de eu
gostaria de terminar essa apresentação
contou outra história
até hoje a história de jéssica é uma das
mães para a paraíba que teve sua criança
ea família
mas se uma coisa o documentário 23 anos
em momentos que eu vi e ouvi essa
história tem um tempo que estava na uti
e nem com ele
já sem vida mas é aproveitar o máximo e
foi aí que eu tomei a decisão
daí fabiana eu vou eu permito que passa
que passou todo o procedimento que for
preciso
se for preciso abrir um pouco a cabeça
para ter alguma coisa o que for preciso
tirar nele só terá eu como mãe se a
missão dele eu como mãe eu permiti que
seja cumprida
se era uma missão será a missão dele vim
passar por tudo isso então eu permito
neste momento de dor mais naquele
momento eu não dava pra parar ali pra
mim a história não ia acabar lei
ali era um recomeço a gente ia viver
ainda muita coisa
mesmo com a partida dele eu não queria
ser egoísta em deixar todas as outras
funções o mundo sem resposta diante de
tanta pergunta vez mais em pesquisa
melhorar as condições de vida dessa
população todos nós
minha esperança é que diante deles a
atitude de horário volta a gente sem
dúvida a gente tem condições de forma
individual ou coletiva e ajudado a
transformar se resolvido pelo menos
diminuir o sofrimento e trazer de volta
o sorriso de ana júlia passar dos anos
do antonico sua equipe e trazer o
sorriso evitando jéssica farias
[Aplausos]
[Música]